son garage fait vraiment partie de l'adn
il reste un exemple la jeunesse
africaine parce que il a osé inventer
l'avenir thomas sankara est devenue
immortelle aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cette jeunesse dont la plupart n'étaient
pas nés au temps de saint cannat mais
leur ferveur
je peux le dire plus avoir tente que
ceux qui le reconnaît je pense que ce
qui explique cela chez nous c'est un
génie politique
gelly capable dans des situations
parfois
n'espérez à ce type de solutions
originales et inattendues et qui restent
valables et plusieurs dessiner après
avoir un homme qui a vécu et qui a été
capable de sacrifier toute sa vie pour
montrer le chemin à suivre ou montrer
qu'il est qu'il est possible d'avoir des
solutions africaines aux problèmes
africains et je traquais la jeunesse
voit un seul à un moyen de s'en sortir
je pense que la ferveur autour de thomas
sankara 34 ans après son décès il y est
d'une part au fait que c'est un
personnage contemporain on a beaucoup de
jeunes qui ont grandi dans l'ombre la
mémoire de thomas sankara et donc on a
un peu l'impression que toute la
jeunesse de jean et berry tiers de cette
figure 2
d'autre part les idées qu'ils
préconisaient les combats qu'il mène à
l'époque sont toujours d'actualité des
questions d'environnement les questions
de justice et qui sociale les questions
d'équité et enfin c'est quand même une
figure qui a pu bénéficier d'un certain
nombre d'archivés des discours des
grands défis des chansons qui le rendent
absolument vivant
[Musique]
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui au pouvoir
dans les différents secteurs
administratifs publics ont privé mais ce
sont les enfants de sa carrière ce sont
les enfants de la révolution
les valeurs qui est un pur
onéreux qui sont chargées les incarnent
aujourd'hui je vais sûrement cités d'or
pour dieu vous le canard et
rend kaboré car il est au milieu des
autres prêteurs qu'est ce qui est le
barca c'est le seul qui est habillé d'un
automate faire avec tête du peloton
cultivated à tisser au burkina ou zip à
l'intérieur et ça c'est déjà tout un
symbole car tous les domaines
l'industrie la santé partout il avait
des idées et ses idées sont encore un
très bel exploit
[Musique]
dès que j'ai pris fonction alors tant
que président du mémorial thomas sankara
la première visite que gérant lui
c'était pas des citoyens venus saluer
toute l'action qu'ils ont fait depuis
leur existence et notamment aux gobelins
sélection ou non pas seulement ils se
sont organisés ou obliger le président
blaise compaore fuir
mais dès le lendemain conformément aux
options
thomas sankara est sorti effectivement
du paysage politique en tant que tel vu
qu'ils portaient aussi des idées
marxistes socialiste nerfs qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement mise à l'écart de
la vie politique africaine et donc il
est rentré effectivement dans l'espace
de la société civile via notamment des
jeunesses africaines les jeunesses des
fonctionnaires et donc on a 100 carats
qui n'est pas forcément mobilisés dans
le cadre notamment de campagnes
politiques ou d'élections
et s'appelle la convergence de l'espoir
il n'a pas été clé pour la conquête du
pouvoir
vous pensez bien ce matin et est clé
elle est habile à venir pour témoigner
de l'action de la révolution et apporter
une voix qui pourrait prendre un billet
éclairer les gens sur cinq sur ce qu'a
été
notre évolution
[Musique]
autour de 100 carats autour de sa
mémoire autour de sa vie des communautés
afroaméricaine
afro vénézuélienne même en europe se
réunissent pour parler de son combat il
a porté la voix du burkina faso nous
montre le monde entier il a fait
énormément de voyage aussi bien dans les
pays de l'est l'ouest il a sillonné le
continent africain et thomas sankara
c'est un personnage qui était son bras
dans les relations internationales
puisqu'il a pris position indépendance
de la nouvelle calédonie pour le peuple
palestinien pour le peuple sahraoui pour
le nicaragua où un certain nombre de
bugs du monde entier qui du coup les le
lui rendent parfaitement et font de
thomas sankara parfois même l'une de
leurs figures dominantes et donc la
dimension internationaliste sankara fait
qu'il a justement cette aura mondiale
pas fous les pays les états les nations
ont besoin pour le moment la mémoire à
travers des personnages exemple est nous
avons ce personnage il est méritoire à
mémorial et d'important pour se
recueillir déjà et pour rappeler ce qu'a
été la vie de thomas sankara heads et
ses compagnons de rendre hommage à une
figure qui est essentiel dans l'histoire
du burkina faso de l'afrique du
panafricanisme et des relations
internationales mesure de et il n'y a
pas de temps parce que les corps
ont été récupérés par la justice pour
les analyses donc aujourd'hui si vous
accueillez sert concerne l'entente où il
y a deux yeux il ya d'abord d'un statut
selle large parce qu'il y en a plus
prisés hier le bureau devant lequel il a
été assassiné c'est vraiment
parmi les 8000 visiteurs mensuels du
mémorial il ya beaucoup de corps qui
viennent nul doute que plus tard un
passage
tous les étudiants et tous les élèves de
kita faso
vulgarisation
je suis sûr que les générations futures
vont reprendre cet héritage et vont
faire encore mieux en tout cas c'est
l'autre espoir aujourd'hui que ce que
nous n'avons pas pu terminer que
d'autres viennent l'enrichir est
terminée et faire avancer
maastricht
[Musique]